lizzy is just supreme it's mesmerizing
to watch her play that character she has
such commands she's the first person to
light up the room and not take it or
herself at all seriously
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Applause]
we should tell him the truth
let's talk first about this movie being
the most anticipated movie of this year
more pre-sale tickets than any other
movie this year in the first 24 hours
number one congratulations and number
two how does it feel to have the fans
just
utterly thrilled to see this thing
utterly terrifying but really really
really thrilling you know it's just a
it's a combination of both because
obviously expectations are high and i
hope i hope the film delivers i haven't
seen it yet and it's fully pledged
i guess the first 20 minutes and it is
lovely good good good i mean there's a
lot there's i think there's a lot
there's a lot in here there's a lot in
there it's an epic film there's no doubt
about that the scale of it is is
definitely
yeah it's in line with some of the
bigger ensemble films we've seen in
recent years that both he's been a part
of that the mcu has delivered so
to sort of be in the mix of that is just
is great and he's such a fantastic
character to play i adore him and all
his
flaws and all his strengths and to take
the multiverse and this phase of the mcu
in a new direction is
really really exciting
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
let's talk doctor strange and wanda
teaming up talking about that dynamic a
little bit it's fascinating oh man you
know i mean
lizzy is just supreme it's mesmerizing
to watch her play that character she has
such commanders she's just come off the
back of you know amazing series of one
division when she started with us so
she's so consummate as a professional
and it's um
it's a real pleasure to watch her work
but also just to be in her company she's
the first person to light up the room
and not take it or herself at all
seriously
and uh and humanize any situation and
it's just a good day when she's on set
and that character and strange together
is such a potent combination it's i
can't wait for fans to see what happens
dr christine palmer is back what can you
tease us about a romance revival i know
in the bit of the little touch that i
got to see there are some very loaded
scenes there and i mean you guys were
saying a lot without saying much and it
was beautiful there's some there's some
stuff going on between them for sure
it's an interesting journey he goes on
in this film he's made this decision to
do things on his own and i think he's
coming up against the fact that's not
necessarily the best way of doing things
and even though the ego of old is kept
in check by the fact he's doing things
with the greater good rather than his
own career
and self-fulfillment he's now a
superhero with all the self-sacrifice
that involves he's still
called up short in his methodology and i
think he realizes that giving too much
away he's better off
doing things
with others than he is doing them on his
own and holding the knife and trying to
control everything isn't always the way
to do things
we get to see various versions of doctor
strange in this was there was there a
version that that stuck out to you for
any reason that you enjoyed getting
ready to play i mean i can't i can't
really say too much about that sadly
because the film's not out yet but um i
enjoyed stretching this character both
as the one we love and know through his
journey in this film but also to explore
other versions of him that have made
other choices in different circumstances
with different different outcomes i
think that's the kind of
wonderful sort of reflection of fantasy
that this multiverse
narrative provides us we live multiple
versions of ourselves every day whether
it's performing professionally or being
at home and
all our role play in life and so to see
that extrapolated in this epic scale was
was great fun for the character and
great fun for me is that i imagine i
mean i imagine it's a lot to get my
teeth
[Music]
i want to ask the importance of the
lgbtq plus representation not only in
this movie yeah but in all of our films
how important is that and how lovely is
it to see you know i wish i wish it
wasn't as important as it is i mean i
wish we were living in a world of
equality and acceptance and inclusion
but
seemingly especially in light of this
film being banned in certain countries
because of
the inclusion of an lgbtq plus character
it's it's amazingly necessary and
sadly those those attitudes are
expectedly disappointing um
it's just it's a shame in a way but
you know she's a really feisty character
she's a strong
kick-ass new element to the mcu
as well as representing both in her
sexuality and family backstory i mean
her sexuality that's the thing that
needs to be explored there's you know
she's arrives in this universe and
you'll see what her story is about i'm
sure there's a lot more to to discover
about her but certainly she comes from a
family of two mothers and but her
importance in this film and her
importance in the mcu is staggering as
well as what she represents fans are
also excited you're coming back to snl
may 7th what what do you take with you
from your from your first experience to
this experience oh gosh i think the main
takeaway is is just try and enjoy it
it's a real ride and it's it's one that
once you're on it just goes so fast it's
like a blink of an eye thing and it's
gone and
you know a lot of cortisol and
adrenaline because of live television
it's just you know there's no there's no
way of flexing that muscle or just or
trying your hand at it in any other
in any other realm really so it's it's
pretty unique in that experience so it's
it's not something you can prepare for
but having done it once i'm just hoping
i'm hoping to be able to settle into it
and just enjoy it even more than i did
the first time